okay what's going on here what do you
got your hand there I have the samsung
GX 20 Wow let's see that's DSLR to dsi
my eyes are not deceiving me yes it's
the SLR 14 megapixels 14.6 I 14.6 for
fourteen hundred dollars so that works
out to be no that's I'm not really gonna
back okay hundred dollars a megapixel we
shot with this camera we did you shot
with a semi nearly SAT there and watched
you we shoot with it we sort of doubled
up we use this camera to shoot some
other products we're reviewing for
gadget lab excuse the french watches yes
and the results were pretty interesting
i think he said like there's some some
the black levels were a little bit weird
yeah the dynamic range of the the image
sensor was not as nice as I'd like it to
be or as I'd seen in other consumer DSLR
source of the canada nikon right lower
models which this would probably
directly compete with so what does that
equate to like our colleges shadows were
really muddy yeah in these files and the
highlights were blown out there wasn't
really a lot of room to yeah you're
showing me that you showed me like one
watch that we took a picture of there
was a little bit of it that was like
textured right yeah and that really
didn't come across yeah all the two very
well the texture was gone no matter what
I did to bracket for some reason the
sensor just couldn't hold up okay okay
actually another thing I noticed about
this when we were shooting the watches
is that it almost looked like they were
running a noise filter over every photo
that you shot whether there's a JPEG or
a rock capture when we open up the files
I showed you yeah it looked like these
watches had been shot through it like a
Vaseline covered lens yeah yeah they're
very first it was kind of a neat effect
but it wasn't intentional no it wasn't
intentionally I couldn't find a way to
easily shut it off right so that was
kind of a pain so what did you end up
doing Jen I'm just going back into like
Photoshop yeah we had a very touching
that we had to sharpen it manually
probably more so than you'd like to do
right you know overall I'd say the the
image file was pretty decent it was
noiseless at 800 is 0 which is pretty
good and also probably because they were
running all those noise filters but that
interns soften the whole image so in
terms of media like what kind of media
it takes a SD horse takes a micro SD
micro SD card and look at that pops up
in the back I don't necessarily like
using me as I feel like that flimsy in
this door is like on a spring which will
eventually break at time no question
feels a little junkie they claim that
this is a sand in and water sealed and
it does have a nice rubber grip and yeah
some ceiling here but if you get to drop
these it wealthier ethically it should
be okay it should be but uh it feels a
little like feels a little elastic rent
because this camera was developed with
pentax so Samsung pentax kind of got
together had a few drinks one thing led
to another and they developed a
proprietary CMOS sensor oh wow that's
pretty sexy it's sexy yeah they also
share the pentax bayonet mount okay so
you can use several pentax lenses okay
they'll fit I will fit onto this camera
someone who already has a lot of pentax
lenses might be wise to get a camera I
could get you get a do this yeah this is
actually the update to the pentax k10d
okay this has a bigger LCD screen I was
like two point seven inches it says it
has image stabilization built into the
body that's not quite the case ah is it
I don't think it works very well for it
we tried it yesterday and wasn't super
successful yeah so like you were doing
and you were just like taking pictures
at a normal a so right it was like we
had a high iso iso a fast shutter speed
and there was still motion blur and it
just shouldn't have happened you're
right uh fourteen hundred dollars 14
megapixels available right now go get it
if you look pentax yeah and sample and
blurry images
hey Danny right what you got there I'm
holding the new blackberry bold here the
new beau well the new old bold we first
saw the bold about back in May nineteen
twenty yeah yeah nike not six yeah the
CEO my closet is came in and showed it
to us and it was pretty cool we were
pretty impressed with it at the time so
what's been the hold up well out
november fourth right did come out of
november fourth but the thing was that
there was some problems with the FCC ah
and so it was it was just delay after
delay after delay the bold is a
non-touchscreen okay i pray phone that
would be the storm now do the storm
that's coming out in december okay this
is the very first blackberry on the
market it has 3 3g basically it has
Wi-Fi and 3g right but we found in our
testing when we were using it we would
get it on a Wi-Fi network like our home
Wi-Fi network we go 15 feet away from
that Wi-Fi network and what would happen
drop it would drop it would switch over
to 3g even if we had full signal on
Wi-Fi okay it would just switch over to
3g and 3gs a lot slower it is in Wi-Fi
what tends to be for business users i
mean is that gonna be a big thing you're
traveling a lot not really no no no
because business users are you know
really if ever close to like Wi-Fi
networks will be using the 3g talk to me
about battery yeah so battery life was
cut you hold us I do sure a better life
thanks battery life on this guy was not
very good black I think rim claims 13.5
hours on Stanley yeah you might call
that a rim job uh it's not we got four
hours out of it for four and a half of
battery life rented a little rejiggering
of the interface yeah they get a little
rejiggering your interface it's a little
bit more cluttered he used to be and if
you look on here all the icons are
unlabeled so yeah so it only there only
light up and tell you what icons era
when you actually are selecting
highlighting so you don't know i mean
like that what the hell this looks like
i don't even know what that means what
is that as a brevi cv the salt cellular
video ok ok no not my resume yeah that
phone looks like there's arrows so my
shooting arrows into it right but that's
a classic hola right right
who the hell wants this thing so who the
hell was it so basically black bear is
going to release the storm yes remember
sometime in December we've heard I know
this is a touchscreen blackberry I've
played with it it's awesome I could
definitely drunk their whole have to
have the canoe jackets yeah yeah so it
could very well be in a true iphone
killer but thing is that's only gonna be
offered on verizon as far as we know
yeah now if you are like a blackberry
nut job menu there's no phone above
blackberry for you and you don't want an
iphone and you're on ATT and the bold is
it definitely very solid choice still
the best this sander this is the best
this is the best blackberry for ATT
drive right now that we see try to rate
it on a scale of one to ten I I think I
don't want to 10 scale it would probably
be seven so it's good but it's not great
but it's good okay good good device if
you have 18t you're definitely and you
you want a blackberry this is born again
you don't want to switch to verizon if
you don't want to switch your rise in
when the storm comes out then get the
blackberry bold if however you are you
know thinking about getting a blackberry
but you're not sure what Carrie to go
with then wait for the storm to come out
we're gonna go to wait for it and go
with verizon i look at this thing this
looks like a home pregnancy test right
here Danny I have I have good news for
you what is it you're having a baby all
right my baby oh no
you